wren's mobile is a gas station in
amherst massachusetts renault gladou has
run that station for nearly 50 years but
because of higher costs he's had to
close
and i'll gladly joins us now with his
son jeff who is the station's manager
thank you both uh for coming on tonight
so you thanks for joining us tucker to
you mr you've you've run it for almost
five decades now
can you be specific and tell us why
you're closing now sad
uh the reason why
i'm ready to close is because of the
high prices of gas that i
refuse to
pass on to my consumers
yeah which are more than
half
our senior citizens
that have been with me for
48 or some odd years
what a horrible story so jeff you've
obviously grown up around this business
and now you're in it
you talk to people who buy gas for five
dollars a gallon
there are a lot of people on fixed
incomes in your apartment what does it
mean to them
it's gut wrenching honestly it is and uh
like my dad said
started working for my dad when i was 10
years old just tagging along on
saturdays and on holidays and and
weekends
and that was the highlight of my life
you know being side by side with him and
and being out here
and most of those customers back in the
in the late 70s early 80s were in their
40s and 50s and now
as we've as we've all moved on in our
lives now we're getting them in their
twilights of their lives and it's we we
had a lady come in here the other day
absolutely crying because her husband
died years ago
and she's never put gas in her car so
she's like how do i put gas in my car my
dad and i
along with my son ty have offered to
take any senior citizen in our area
that's one of our customers to an
additional station one of our
competitors no doubt to fill up their
tanks because
we we love our customers so much
but you're closing so you get three
generations working there your family's
revolved around this business for 48
years and you're closing it how do you i
mean how do you feel about that
it's heartbreaking but i mean uh
we're closing the gas the gas portion of
it
repair-wise and used-car business will
try to keep aboard as long as we can but
the bread and butter for us is gas and
uh
and and we've been in a bad contract
with our supplier for the last five
years we've asked them to uh to to get
out of the contract and they're holding
it above us to to not let us out now
mobile is leaning on them because of all
the negative publicity that's come from
this
so they sent up their their territory
manager as well as the vice president of
of operations the other day to ask us
how they could how they could fix this
how can we make this stop
my dad said let us out of our contract
they said we can't do that let us give
you
gas a little bit cheaper than what
you're paying for it now maybe extend
the terms of your of your uh payment for
the gas and give you some new gas pumps
how would you feel about that my dad
said
we're done we're done that's it we we're
we're no longer gonna we're no longer
gonna supply you gas so another family
business goes under
gentlemen good good luck to you thank
you for sharing your story tonight
that's just the saddest thing thank you
you bet
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight